this video is brought to you by expressvpn
and Shopify people more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
we are here for what if season 2 episode
two today joined by Koy jandre Koy we just
watched episode one did you love it loved it
flabbergasted confused excited for more you
got to watch our reaction to that ladies and
Gentlemen please go ahead leave a like on this
video that'd be very much appreciated also tell
us in the comments down below what do you think
of this episode of episode 2 if you're here that
means you already watched it so tell us what
you think people people think thoughts they
might not have then they yell us were talking
too much I don't know why they're here why are
they talking over the the show I want to watch
well maybe watch the show yeah watch the show
leave a like while you're at it too leave a like
also subscribe and click the notification Bell
get notifi when our reaction for episode three
is up here on the Chanel thank you to prep for
helping us seted down these highlights you guys
are champions also uh full length Reaction watch
s where you sync up with your own copy of
what if that is available for super sexy
rejects thank you to all who have been joining
helping us have the most uccessful year at our
patreon thus far Coy you ready to get into it
let's do two we don't know what the titles for
any of these are we going blind we have no idea
what we're walking into right now but let's do
it Commander do you have eyes on the
target barely it's moving fast is that
gorgeous animation again copy that weapon fire it
will Dragon Ball Z it's going down where
1988 oh it's going to be that episode oh
the 80s Avengers episode oh cool
I right I assume you destroyed a
generic water building the year I
was born Aqua yes who's in the egg
rits right there I can see you a Star-Lord is
that a kid not just any kid but Peter Quill yeah
a son of Earth and the Stars whose pain and loss
now threatens to destroy the very world he once
called home oh and the entire universe along
with it oh no he went the way ego wanted him
to that's dope that's a fun what if I love that
that's again more like the comics like what if
have something big John Slattery oh Howard Stark
here Chris Hemsworth's back oh Lawrence Fishman's
back okay oh I saw Sebastian Stan I'm wondering
if they're gonna set it like he came back in the
80s instead 6 months earlier the ravagers were
dispatched to abduct Peter Quill from his home
world oh so it right away right away yeah and
chose to raise him as his own and the ego got
pissed but in this universe yandu never had his
change of heart so he turned Peter over to his
father the celestial being known as ego he's
pretty you won't be needing these anymore Peter
no let's play catch ego called it the expansion to
remake the universe in His image and with his son
now at his side he had all the power he needed
absolute power corrupts kids absolutely orbital
intelligence has retraced his steps across dozens
of nearby solar systems Ric pegas this okay Cosmic
radiation within 24 hours of his arrival Peggy
Aging in real time this kid has an entire nuclear
Arsenal csing through his veins with that kind
of Firepower I don't know that there's a person
on Earth who can stop him it's like a breit bur
situation yeah not one person working alone but a
team made up of the best our little planet has to
offer Peggy assembles The Avengers in a matter of
minutes Howard at the rate he's going our planet
Won't Last a Day we need help okay who's on our
roster yes there's no vegetable the potato chips
are the vegetable oh Ant-Man yeah Michael Douglas
and you're supposed to be a scientist and you're
supposed to like potato chips godamn hope you're
such a pain in the ass J say you Hank please
don't hang up oh that's right him and Howard
got their beef yeah yeah turn on the TV what the
aircraft's occupant was send the plane one step
ahead of you awesome this is their Hulk like The
Avengers Assemble over the Hulk and this is like
the Insight against that's great used to work
sweetie not anymore this is so cool smart to keep
the relationship between them yeah what Foster
oh my goding it's me Qui I guess technically Loki
would be the better parallel but let's like at the
Loki threat wow who's the guy in the armor King
tachaka oh tachaka it's a pleasure your father was
a great Ally to US during the war yes I understand
you even donated some vibranium to your efforts
we made a shield out of lost it in the Arctic but
cool ORF wanted the target contained before he
reaches Moscow so he sent the Winter Soldier yes
o oh oh love it great attention and detail
like Bucky heard the rumor perfect even if
they're true the man we knew is long gone pig and
we have bigger fish to fry I miss winter soldiers
so much what a cool moment why is this season
off to such a better start it's so much better
these are actual what if Comics it's using
multiple characters it's actually weaving a
big enough story are we even going to be able
to intercept him in time New York's a long way
from the Mojave Desert not in my ride hello Dr
Wendy Lawson US Air Force Wendy Lawson uniform
doesn't really look like Air Force it's not
it's cre Star Force they met the cre in the
80s I guess pre 90s Captain Marvel Catman space
BR giant man silent but deadly good to see you
and you're going to be the Crusty guy I was just
saying I love how you get a fun side of Hank Pim
yeah young instead of just a km that's more
Ant-Man in the comics yeah it's perfect this
kid puts on quite a show well you better that
child take him out bre bur duck a PR bunch of
Rocket raccoons it's also paced more like a
movie he does not look all that threatening
books can be deceiving you think the leader of a
technological superpower that masquerades a third
world country would appreciate that or those
foxes okay I'm at the crash site moving in to
secure the Pod ship now everybody in position
relax I got the perimeter go jant yeah my go I
seem to remember you maxing out at 21 ft yeah
I made some adjustments he figured the end the
world go big or go home you two are finished
measuring your States if you can isolate the
kid you should be able to trap him in the
photon grid you cover the Trap I'll handle
the boy oh great sense of scale that's perfect
what's the matter kid what something bugging you
nice done luring him to your position now Tech's
Advanced it's going to take me a minute to crack
it smart to do small things that he wouldn't
necessarily attack right away I really feel
like they're taking advantage of their
animation this time with the Ant-Man stuff
yeah and it's so much more cinematically
paced than the first season I remember
being resistance will only make
this more difficult my young friend
not the move T Chaka I feel like Peter would
anate I got him oh no oh no
cool pull back killer if the cub
in that jet blows there won't be
a planet left to stay shoot him
Winter Soldier shoot that child
has Sebastian Stan spoke at all he
hasn't spoken yet but he's in the cast
great use of scale and animation Problem Child
12:00 does anyone have a plan dope
Avengers lineup I've got a plan
Retreat okay let's go just weird
presence it's like a weird goth character
Thor no way is see that big of a threat yeah
this is his first time on earth oh it would
be yeah is it really you if you are referring
to your doom then yes I thought you were the
dude from Van Halen yodenheim was the first to
fall Asgard soon thereafter oh [__] perished
at that boy's hands damn until this realm Earth
was all that remained it is like The Avengers
movie with him showing up yeah OS use them to
implant his Essence on the planets Across the
Universe I recovered Earths on my way here
from a place called Missouri the seedling is
protected by a veil of cosmic energy only a being
of celestial origin can penetrated we have one in
custody you'll be the way to Wi was heart and
I love that she's doing the Star-Lord entrance
and it's starlord yeah good he's going to
see this good catch cool song though it's
always been one of my mom's favorites it
was my mom loved it too oh yeah you guys
can Bond over your mom's 80s music you don't
seem so bad given where you're from let him
out he's fine little black widow Loki scene
she's going to be manipulating him because I
was was born in the USA why else do you think
I'd [__] 10,000 light years to get here I'm
just trying to get home security breach or he
manipulated her yeah or it's the switch where
are my particles and where's hope and where's
my key card she jacked everything oh little
Hulk containment unit oh man he Gass at you girl
that was crazy I noticed a bus stop about a mile
out he doesn't need a bus bu up no and here I
want you to have this oh there you go this is
your mom's look it's a long ride to Missouri
and she'd be glad to know I'm sharing thanks
a this does seem tender you guys are making a
mistake Peter's not behind all this it's his
dad he says he's like a weird alien space Scot or
something yeah great blame the absentee father we
need to study him we need to kill him he's a
threat even without the seedling he speaks MCR
speaks so long as the boy lives this planet will
never be safe and is that not what we're here to
ensure you're here to do the right thing Peter
deserves our help as much as anyone she reminds
me of Steve hey Peter why can't hear me why can't
I connect with my son noise cancelling headphones
from 8 eight I guess I'll have to finish what he
started myself uh thunder guy is it supposed to be
doing this the seedling is Awakening another alien
vessel about to make landfall right outside oh Man
Kung Fu well guess that's the dad girl was right
wouldn't I love to have that printed on a t-shirt
this actually feels like it's part of the MCU
can't fight them both Let them fight each other
Lawson tell me you've got eyes on that kid up some
Cosmic radiation that's definitely not of this
world but how would Star-Lord beat him he may be
our only hope of stopping dear old dad you really
think a child is going to be so willing to fight
his own father you're not a parent are you indey
whoa It's like Man of Steel
yeah there's the Fright
burn
cool better yet it's more like Last
Jedi I mean my preference or has
God not going to go great for you Thor hand
over the seedling and this will all be over
so if you've come to destroy us you're going to be
leaving here very disappointed I've come to save
you it's always nice they say spreading covering
all that exists until every part of you is is me
me guys got a bit of an
ego faceless henchman it's been
a while if you will not give us
back what is ours we will take it from
you never mind they're all him faced
minions let's take out all those Kurt
Russell cool Avengers assembling oh great
shot ohc that was really
cool they have really thrown down way more
of the animation yeah it actually yeah yeah
there's a tangibility oh I got to go
bigger There's an actual set of scale
which Ant-Man 3 did not have for Antman
not evenia did yeah Winter Soldier do you
copy just shoot the boy he is busy trying to
kill this kid the Americans have located the
target I'm Hank hope Dead everything that's
happening it's not me me Tim he has this
power to to get inside my head see Winter Soldier
should be able to identify with that but he's not
clear yet come on let's go yeah oh cool oh man the
combination of like the the shifting around with
that the size and even with a hammer yeah they're
really good at the z-axis up and down and out I
thought maybe if I came back here I wouldn't feel
so alone without my mom it doesn't even feel like
home anymore die it's like face off Stand Down
Soldier I intercepted your Handler's transmission
it's just you and me pal there is no me hold that
cool edit I like that since we lost Hope's mom
our home hasn't felt the same either the pain
the loneliness I know it can feel like you're
drowning in it but I haven't and you don't have
to either listen Howard Bucky when you see that
kid all you see is a Target but I see a future
the life he can lead the good he can do monetary
gains he's been overwhelmed how would you have
hostiles inbound come join our family Bucky please
well kid what do you say he wants to adopt him
little brother Stark little brother Pim I mean
oh I didn't know I actually didn't know if it
wasn't animated I I wouldn't know more but because
it's animated I was like ain't going to shoot they
had some dark what of season one episodes I was
like maybe they kill going to shoot a kid no the
seedling someone doesn't stop that seedling we are
done for I can't break free no not going to make
it just taing his head we're not going to make
it oh as if on Q Wendy crusty jump let's finally
see what this girl can do okay here we go
yeah we got it you're alive what you seem
to have fallen in with the wrong crowd this
is my mom's home and I can't just let
you destroy it but that's the more in
you Peter everything dies except us how could
you say that my mother you said you loved her
I like Guardians of the Galaxy 2 as well yep
I enjoy it look at this father son struggle
you don't have the power to destroy me but
you do a little bit of you will always live
inside of me yes I've always known you
turn out to be a disappointment this is
moving a little fast for me now yeah it's all
a sudden it's like we got to get to the Third
act man it looks great though
looks great like visually it's
awesome
yes Winter Soldier just shoots him in the head
it's time I found you most vulnerable what you
call it uh light beer how exotic another
chick St as goose yes the Winter Soldier
may be out there but I'm pretty sure Bucky
Barnes is out there with him he took off
the eyes Shadow but he did not find a change of
clothes still wearing most of the suit boy may
have destroyed ego's Caporal form but his Planet
still lives perhaps you forgot Goldilocks we have
sort of a team thing going on here yeah yeah
then I suggest you CH up team oh they got to
avenge hope she didn't be there nope she has no
powers she actually just betrayed everyone not
trustworthy almost caused the end of the Earth
hope can't be trusted guys should just because
you know not lever it is take your daughter work
day hereditarily she's important so uh yeah liked
it still more than the first season but you know
what I still love what do you love them sponsors
baby thank you to Shopify for sponsoring which
is what we use for our merch store and is our
gamechanging partner in e-commerce so whether
you're launching a passion project or scaling
to new heights Shopify is Ecommerce Powerhouse
guiding you at every step from creating your
first online store to opening physical locations
Shopify makes it seamless it's perfect whether
you're selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their all-encompassing
platform for both online and inore sales their
checkout system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than other
platforms and let's not forget Shopify magic
their AI tool that elevates your business with
minimal effort but seriously reflecting on your
journey using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition smooth
growth exponential thank you again reject Nation
from simplifying sales to scaling our offerings
Shopify has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us owers 10% of us
e-commerce backing business businesses big and
small in over 175 countries there are war-winning
support always there to guide you so ready to
join the revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com reex all overc case
shopify.com reex start your Shopify success story
now let's grow together with Shopify team big
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this video
a real game changer I've been using for years
that's right years so whenever they want to work
with us it's an instant yes you've likely heard
about expressvpn for online privacy and security
but there's more to it than that however there
was a very real incident recently with Spectrum
Shing down my internet and contacting me due to
a suspecting hacking attempt and funny enough I
realized I hadn't actually activated my expressvpn
on my new laptop that I got a couple of months ago
so I was paying the consequences having faced
a serious hacking issue on YouTube a couple
years ago that made expressvpn my go-to for both
security and freedom I mean it and yes what you
heard is true believe me this channel knows you
can use expressvpn to watch movies and shows on
Netflix that are not available in your country
this means accessing a vast rate of content of
over a 100 countries like a global cinema at
your fingertips it's super easy open Express
VPN switch locations refresh the browser and
there you have it whether it's kdramas on South
Korean Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube or more
expressvpn has you covered and it's incredibly
fast ensuring no buffering or lag for smooth HD
streaming it's versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles Smart
TVs and more this means you can enjoy your
favorite shows at anywhere any screen protect
and elevate your internet experience so if you
want to get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you can get
an extra 3 months of expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to expressvpn.com
reex to learn more thank you again anyway K before
I interrupted you with my very important messages
from people who have made life possible to breathe
uh what what did you think of the episode uh I
liked it more than a lot of the first season
wasn't quite as strong as the uh first episode
for me because we both had the exact same moment
of like well that was rushed like the uh if the
episode had gotten like five more minutes um it
would have been I I the conversation between ego
and his son was all of a sudden like I've always
hated you and I was like whoa or I've always
expected this of you kind of turned quickly um
it was like the ending of Guardian it a lot like
Guardians 2 it was a lot it was like 30 minutes at
Guardians 2 condensed into 30 seconds maybe less
yeah I mean I'm assuming you know everyone that's
seen Guardians 2 if you're watching this you've
seen Guardians 2 but it did make the episode feel
like it was a little disjointed um overall though
man I I this was my most anticipated episode next
to the uh the the Mad Max episode um from the
trailer uh but this like delivered for me I I love
the80s Avengers um The Avengers is a is a comic
that I've enjoyed since I started reading comics
so it was cool to see some of the characters in
The iteration that was not quite the comic but
like more familiar um it was great to see that
team Dynamic I thought it was really cool how
they much like the Jos Weeden Avengers played
their power set off each other and we we talked
a lot about the use of the vectors and the size
and scale and the directing I was really impressed
overall overall yeah I mean I still think uh comp
there it it started off stronger to me and got a
little weaker as it went personally for me um and
I was trying to figure it out because I was trying
to hold on to like the the jovial that the episode
was filling me with because I was like oh this
is really cool we are doing alternate versions
of our Avengers and having a form in an earlier
era um but it kind of did just kind sort of go
down the path of the things that I thought were
a little lackluster story-wise of what if season
1 where by the time we I didn't really feel like
we got to see the uniqueness or distinctiveness
of all the Avengers characters that that's the
appeal of putting them here yeah after a while
it's like okay yeah when they're first introduced
when they're at Coney Island and they're fighting
you get a tease of that then I thought it would
be like more Amplified by the time you get to
the finale instead it was a similar fight but
different similar five just with a bunch of
faceless PE like a bunch of like ego duplicates
and they essentially did plot points similar to
another movie that we've already seen also the
Captain Marvel stand didn't didn't do anything
didn't do jack [__] right yeah yeah what was her
name who was that I don't know uh Dr Wendy Lawson
Marvell oh she's Marvel right but like she didn't
get that's what I mean like a Marvel standing she
didn't get to do anything yeah no she didn't do
anything no but she's more like the character
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um yeah I didn't think
she really provided anything new so I thought like
in the be the first chunk of it was when I thought
we were going to do something really it felt like
it was it was really interesting setup of okay
what if Star-Lord was abducted instead given to
Ego and he turned and it seemed like he actually
wasn't evil no like six months he might not have
been corrupted as completely as you know the I it
was still yeah no there's a way to justify it it's
still the setup was infinitely more interesting
than How It ultimately concluded though oh Daman
really what if they have to fight The Avengers
have to fight Star-Lord and he is he has become
the uh Loki of this world effectively yeah he has
become the loky of this world has become the god
that ego wanted him to be essentially yeah like
that is a very interesting setup and and he has
caused all this destruction and what do they do
about it like it was fun I liked hope bonding with
him there was a lot of like really fun things they
were doing and a fun Throwbacks and fun references
like I you know I mentioned with the Hulk scene
and all that stuff that was fun it was great to
see that Tech it was the lasting impression of
the episode that kind of was like all right yeah
I mean it it did feel more like season one as
far as like and we're going to rush to the end
like that that was my big issue with season
one was it would open with a premise that for
me didn't always feel as important as the comics
but then it would definitely like once introduced
rushed to the finish line and this had more of
the pacing of what I had problems with yeah I
mean but what do you guys in the comments think
that did you feel this way about it because for
me yeah I thought like I like getting Michael
Douglas to have have him have be a lot more fun
playing the Ant-Man that we know from the comics
mhm and uh also with Haley Atwell getting to be
old old Peg old Peg yeah in real time I enjoyed
the relationship between her and John Slattery
because we've never really gotten to see a lot of
that between like how they knew Steve differently
and like that relationship as how it pertained
to the Winter Soldier that was all fascinating
yeah yeah and it's it's like aesthetically it
was cool to have you know Goliath there Foster
but I wish we got to get a little again if they if
they actually cut out some of this ego stuff yeah
and they just focused on the Avengers and dealing
with Star-Lord like you need the ego stuff for the
backdrop I get it for the background explanation
and someone to fight since they don't want him
fighting a kid good luck Young Avengers but but
then it would have allowed us to actually zero
in on like what makes King tachaka different than
King tala yeah because he definitely moved uh he
had a bit of Swag like tala but I don't know what
his actual motivations or or personality you know
like hope fan dying little girl got way more flesh
than a lot of the other Avengers yeah that's why
she's a member of the team exactly for without
powers we don't know why like Dr Wendy Lawson
uh like she got more of a like she could have
used more and and so I really think that they
kind of dropped the ball a little bit in terms of
Storytelling in the in the last like I don't know
how the episode like 28 minutes yeah last seven
seven or something like that yeah yeah the third
act would definitely felt like that rush I worry
about so it left so it did kind of leave me a tad
disappointed because it was a little because
everything else leading up to it I thought was
really interesting it kept getting better and
more interesting and then it kind of just went
down a very predictable cliche path it did wrap
itself up as clean as possible like let's make
sure the kids's good yeah where especially after
a compelling episode of last episode right like
the only real complaint I had about last episode
was Ronin again was underused it wasn't really a
character and and but here I'm like oh man they
had all this great stuff and they and they they
didn't really utilize or what instead they just
turned into Guardians too right and I did enjoy
the Avengers setup more than the the delivery so
I I liked the first two acts and it did Rush and
there's something I do like about Hank adopting
yeah that's cute yeah yeah and and I think though
that what last episode showed us is you can do a
little bit more of that mature touch and I think
they could have utilized a little bit more of that
mature handling of it you know like she's hope and
and uh Hank are obviously haunted by the loss
of Janet at this point in the timeline and they
made them so chipper yeah no real reference except
for the the great prop and they could have used a
tad bit of like emotional weight and I think that
would have actually made the chipper be more felt
if they balance it out so yeah I know I'm doing
a little bit of the like revisionist reviewing
thingy uh but it it was all there that's the
thing that put all there they put those puzzle
pieces down they just didn't connect them yeah
yeah yeah but overall still better than a lot
of season one for me and and the animation still
really spectacular the the sense of scale was cool
and two-thirds of it I still really enjoyed it's
just that last third which is the it's you know
if like the first if the first third was the
weak part to me I wouldn't really be talking
about that but when it's over you're like well
but when it's the last third that is the weakest
part it's what the episode has left me with so I
guess that's why I'm like honing in on it so much
sure yeah yeah I I agree uh better than a lot of
season one not as good as episode one of season 2
good to see those characters wish the ending had
left a little bit more of a resolution that felt
deserved but overall lot of fun all right guys
what do you think about it leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a like and
hey we will uh catch you all soon but before we
do this patr of the day shout out all right John
pick a name Eric hman Eric horsman you know what
I'm going to get you for Christmas this year what
do we got I am going to get you uhuh a you know I
just in my head I was like oh it's Eric it's got
to be a good one and I just got so caught over my
own head of the pressure of it I can't even think
of something right we we can we can Workshop a
couple things open up you know Amazon or Adam and
eve.com you know whatever we need to do I I mean
you get you out of anyone you buy our shirts the
mostest you've got a real reject tattoo oh my God
you know you know what I would love to do but you
got to be on your deathbed in order for me to do
this I really I've really thought about this okay
okay is that when you're on your deathbed yes I
will get an Eric Horseman tattoo yeah I'm like oh
how cool but you got to be in your death bed yes
otherwise you know who knows you can you're going
to be in the room getting the tattoo cuz like you
might be I could get the T like you keep that real
re said to get your name it's like what if he does
something that's like really weird and messed up
and and I'm like ah crap do I really want to be
associated with this guy get a portra I got to
know that you made you made it as a good person
die sure sure so then get your tattoo but you I
got to get before you die because then there's
if you don't see it then there's how am I going to
get on camera and get the views for it you know uh
right it's I got to be he's got to get a reaction
to it I gotta like show it to his place be like
we can we can both do it D subscriber yeah oh wow
John just fallowing my lead well see cuz you can
get his name tattooed oh yeah just totally hop
off my hard work here just piggyback off of my
idea you know what I don't need your tattoo I'll
get David's I mean I'll get Eric something totally
different yeah why not yeah as long as it's not
better than my tattoo then we're okay what are
you going to get him okay uh I am going can't
think of anything can you I I think about his
death already you with Eric's face on them wow
so I can watch the quality go down over time my
tattoo is permanent n dude I'm going to launch a
company in your name call it Eric's cheeks and uh
and I'm going to be strapping people's cheeks
all across this nation with your face right on
the back and it's G to have a it's going to be
you but it's your head on Michelangelo's David
you know so like oh you would be great though if
it was like half of his face on each cheek and
then you have to squeeze your cheeks for face
to come together on the form fitting to your
cheeks so that the effect is always oh gay you
would love that that would yeah imagine I mean
like what I he's openly gay right like I didn't
just out him I would be very surprised if if Eric
Horan was was like what you how dare you reveal
this Eric seems like one of the most assured and
proud people we have ever interacted with so I I
I well I would be very I'm sorry I feel I would be
very surpris I mean I'm going to put you back in
the closet on your deathbed just we could always
cut this out but the internet's forever it's true
so someone's gonna come my pres to you is outing
you and uh and I guess my present
is being an accomplice to that
anyway not looking forward to when
you die but never you're not going
to die we might get a trending video
we will come to your funeral and live
stream it and uh with my Sleepless suit
that day yes so the tattoo is on Full
display yeah and I'll be just strapped in
the underoo nothing else Merry Christmas
Eric